[musique]
sur
Si votre identité est révélée avant, le gouvernement et l'Agence de sécurité nationale nieront tout.
Sera
S'il arrive un moment où je suis gonflé
Ah, ta décision devient la couleur
5 PS Resom
a été déclenché
fais bien maintenant
Parmi le pouvoir fort, la Fédération des syndicats du travail devrait regarder ce qu'ils n'oublient pas.
C'est super facile quand on travaille dur, on est à Séoul.
Rolf
4 République populaire démocratique de Corée Plan Spirituel 2
Maintenant un chapitre de plus
Je veux rencontrer une certaine croissance
Vous tenez bon et travaillez dur, nous devons voir le seul Kim Jong-un capable de tenir le jangdokdae
Diriger une entreprise après avoir été expulsé de l'armée
Il sera facile de croire en la couronne gagnante
Deokso couleur Corée du Sud peut être un désir ardent par la fenêtre
Il devrait être donné au général en chef Lim Jeong-hee.
5 Vous avez déjà envie de bien manger
w
Oh oh oh
[musique]